[Musique]
bonjour mesdames messieurs ici guy moi
je suis responsable du site d' espace
autochtone à radio-canada je vous
souhaite la bienvenue à cette émission
spéciale sur les 30 ans de la crise
d'oka et quand on parle d'une crise on
parle d'une majeure une crise qui a eu
des conséquences sur les relations entre
les autochtones les différents
gouvernements et des conséquences encore
rouges ou alors pour comprendre un peu
dans quel contexte ces faits et s'est
produit cette crise nous avons trois
éviter d'avoir le grand chef de la
communauté de cannes et s'attaquer sans
jeu post estime en chef d' instrument
bien des missions merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation
le chef de l'assemblée des premières
nations québec labrador ghislain picard
et bien sûr le ministre des services aux
autochtones marque
histoire de se retremper dans cette
époque je vous invite à écouter le
résumé de cette crise c'est un et quatre
minutes sur ce qui s'est passé il y a
trente ans seconde ripart après la crise
d'oka rey julien 1990 l'émoicq de cannes
et s'attaquer tiennent depuis cinq mois
une barricade sur un petit chemin de
terre à proximité du golf d'oka il se
pose un projet de condos auquel tient la
municipalité de seclin
ceux ci sont bien vides il n'a jamais
été question de céder un pouce de
terrain qui appartient présentement la
ministre à des docks à le matin du 11
juillet la sûreté du québec se présenta
au corps l'objectif dé faire la
barricade
mais de l'autre côté des lacs de
montagne et saint louis les mois de
kahnawake leur réserve une surprise
ils bloquent le pont mercier
la stratégie des marques sur le pont
appuyer leurs frères de cannes s
attaquer mais aussi déstabiliser la ssq
l'état-major de la sûreté du québec la
pression devient très forte
l'assaut est lancé là est ce qu on doit
battre en retraite
humilié un policier le caporal lemay est
mort mais c'est un miracle qu'il n'y ait
pas eu plus de victimes
et c'était bien camouflé bien caché il
voyait les policiers arriver je répéte
toutes les huiles donc fait un dérapage
énorme ce matin là l'anthropologue
pierre trudel était à l'époque l'un des
rares s'intéresser au moral de la région
de montréal
j'ai commencé à donner des entrevues aux
médias
la jci c'est qu'ils atteignent le ballon
partait de loin pour l'informatique
les morales de kahnawake cours la seule
voie qui relie château dit à montréal
[Applaudissements]
jour après jour la population
châteauguay se rassemblent ou limite qui
sépare la ville et la réserve
l'ambiance est parfois festive mais il
ya surtout beaucoup de frustration et un
grand mépris à l'égard des monts rock
colonnes de figer le royaume ait pas eu
un sou de circulation puis brûlé sous
les applaudissements de la foule
[Applaudissements]
la crèche est frustré et 60 jours au
clap ont été bloqués il avait une grande
statue causait des réels problèmes aux
gens les semaines avancent les
tentatives de négociations semblent
mener nulle part nous pouvons pas
accepter de négocier sous la pression
des armes
excédé le mouvement solidarité
châteauguay dirigée par un ancien
policier la sûreté du québec occupe le
pour le vie de saint louis de gonzague
et bloquent la fois maritime on reste
ici tant qu'elle peut remercier pas
développer la police à nous arrêterons
remorquer les véhicules
il pense que ces cumuls ont là est ce qu
était rien avec force
rien pour calmer les résidents
[Applaudissements]
ces petites bêtes est intervenu au matra
qui arrêtent les manifestants dans notre
top quand les forces armées sont
intervenues sur le ton le tep et robin
doak holtz type super social est discuté
bien autochtone on sait qu'on allait
terminer terrain du losc est plus
dangereux de paix sociale
lorsque l'armée arrive et why aux postés
à kahnawake abandonnent leurs barricades
on découvre alors un imposant arsenal
quand des personnes âgées des enfants -
évacue la réserve des résidents
châteauguay et leur lance une pluie de
projectiles
des dizaines de policiers de la sûreté
du québec sont pourtant sur place ils ne
font qu observer la scène sans broncher
le pour remercier finalement rouvert
l'armée resserre l'étau à cannes et
s'attaquer soldats et oies rieuses sont
maintenant un face-à-face l'image fera
le tour du monde
puis à la fin septembre des derniers
rois yeux et leurs sympathisants essaie
de fuir sans leurs armes
surpris les soldats fusil et baïonnettes
à la main bloquent le passage après 78
jours la crise se termine dans la plus
grande confusion
[Musique]
voilà c'était leur montage d'un jeu de
guerre s'agit sans doute de la crise
politique majeure qu'a connu le canada
dans les 30 dernières années
d'abord vous quels souvenirs gardez-vous
de cette crise
normalement une journée on a les 60
jugent que je me souviens de la journée
à monter dans la fenêtre devant la
fusion des holdings des jeunes hommes et
jeunes femmes beaucoup de mauvais
souvenirs à cause un peu d'anxiété et
eux mêmes championnats le 25ème
anniversaire n'était pas facile quand
j'ai demandé de faire un discours
l'européenne pour commémorer de la crise
d'oka et 5 suivi de ce niveau n'a été
que j'avais su au programme de ces
journées là beaucoup beaucoup de mémoire
oui on peut même parler de choc post
traumatique la vodka chef de gare sauf
erreur
est ce que vous étiez comme journaliste
je pense que vous avez été un moment
donné à la socam
comment vous avez vécu cette crise le
mans les cctp un niveau d'accès des
diverses sens aujourd'hui
à chaque fois qu'il y a
une étincelle potentiel de braquage
l'idée sont comme ça il ya toujours
selon loki qui refait surface mais pour
répondre à votre question j'étais jeune
vécu dans l'ombre politique autochtone
en ce moment je devais présenter ma
nation au sein du conseil devraient qui
dit manquer entre 89 et de les écouter
sans doute parmi les bras mais je veux
bien bien humblement qui a sans doute
entretenu un lien un peu les événements
hackensack et au corps à kahnawake aussi
et je vous entends pas l'éthique au sein
de la nation
à ce moment j'ai même participé à deux
marches de solidarité dans la ville de
québec dans ces années là j'avais
contribué à faciliter le voyage de
certains de nos élus pour participer à
une assemblée spéciale qui avait été
tenu qu'un embargo à pleine période de
crise si on était nombreux doutes que je
crois que le traverser vers la
communauté à partir de la rive venant de
l'est n'aura finalement dans la région
de devoir tout le monde s'est rendu à
cette place en 10 spéciales en bateau
c'était sans doute pour témoigner lors
de la création de vingt ans aussi de
l'importance de de s'assurer que la
pluie était au rendez vous qu en dépit
de tout ce qui a été de tout ce qui a
été soudé comme question mais au sein de
notre communauté par rapport notamment
l'utilisation des angles et je pense que
sauf c'était devenu seront devenus
primaire est prioritaire c'était
finalement de garder de solidarité au
sein d'autres où les solidarités que
qui était finalement validé par le fait
que la passion se retrouver seul en
verlan de la communauté incluant les
forces policières et incluant l'armée
donc c'est ça l'histoire qui ont
contribué à vraiment pas possible cette
idée de solidarité ou blanc de tous les
autres éléments ne seront plus
questionné au complet questionnaire oui
donc d'une part un événement de tout
innocent traumatisant pour les nations
autochtones mais d'autre part avec un
facteur qui est l'outil à unir les
nations autochtones aux bandits revenir
là-dessus fou mark bérubé d'estreux mais
le ciment calculs sont bons vous deviez
avoir 16 17 ans au moment de la crise
oui et évidemment je n'ai pas vécu les
événements que le chef simon ou le chef
picard m'étais j'avais 17 ans
effectivement j'étais seul à défendre et
à valcartier
lorsque des événements se sont se sont
délais j'avais je faisais mon cours d'un
fonds vie un cours de perfectionnement
dans le temps et donc j'ai vu le
déploiement de thèmes régiment j'avais
par contre 4 à mi mots dans mon régiment
avec lesquels j'avais décidé d amitié
évidemment des amitiés de soldats qui
ont dû choisir un deux pays qui était
vouée à servir et à défendre et leurs
familles je souhaite très utile que je
n'ai pas dû faire moi même
évidemment ils ont fait le choix de
famille sont retournés dans leur
communauté ils traitance les juments
dans quel jeu servait il y avait cette
tension évidemment parce qu'on avait des
amis qui étaient qui était qu'était mac
évidemment c'est un déploiement d'être
enfermé à l'intérieur du canada comme
des peuples autochtones donc d'essence
étant très partagés
j'ai eu finalement des habiletés des
deux côtés du conflit
mais pas servi moi même je n'ai pas été
déployés
mais j'ai vécu et j'ai vu ces moments de
façon vive et géorgiens des mémoires à
ce jour mêmes vieux les publicités des
amis dont les renouer avec lesquels j
renouer ses amis de spa sud quelques
années après mais jarjat retiennent-ils
d'aidé souvenir très vif
oui bon temps quand on garde le fond du
problème
on a l'impression que le le le ce fonds
ne reprenne n'a pas été réglé il ya
quelques semaines les innu de région de
oicha tu mates malioténam ont bloqué
l'accès à la rivière moisie
derrière ça c'est toujours l'enjeu
territoire à cannes est attaqué l'enjeu
du doigt les voix de ces moteurs c'était
toujours l'enjeu du territoire quand il
ya une tension
il faut toujours chercher derrière il ya
toujours la question du territoire où ça
bloque le franchissement ou simple pour
qu'on en arrive pas avec le no more
fédéral ou même avec les gouvernements
provinciaux à avoir ces fameuses entend
en ce qui concerne le territoire mais ça
va dépendre de la première nation
mettions parce que on nous dit les
enjeux et les ressources sécurité il ya
toutes sortes de choses sur table quand
on frappe un mur avec un gouvernement
mais c'est aussi la reconnaissance un
seul set autochtone qui existe et c'est
ce qui est difficile à surmonter parce
que comme vous avez entendu le tir au
stand pour un euro indre et dieu
municipal m'inscrire et à disposer chez
nous
la municipalité d'oka aussi la courant à
l'égard de sa promesse par très peu
traité la miss paris nos conneries tu
peut exister des concessions on se rend
ce lundi on se retire on essaie de faire
des gestes de bonne foi dit souvent
c'est donc côté de la table la mentalité
colonialiste crise autochtone devrait
s'en remettre dedans ça fait longtemps
qu'on n'a plus besoin de revisiter les
traiter de ce rapport rapport avec nous
non mais nous on souffre encore des
séquelles
le tueur depuis des générations la peur
du territoire à la perte de langlade des
ressources et civilisationnel puis on
voit la chance de batailler lido c'est
non développé ça dérange pour grand
chose
ça s'est fait de la vague mais non c'est
toujours énormément difficile de faire
un petit pot la crise au corps on dirait
qu'elle a tout un jeu beaucoup de temps
à trouver le pays mon service et de la
crise du cancer jusqu'à quel point il
serait allé parce que la crise doit nous
amener sur le précipice de précipices
d'une guerre civile est possible de la
mer déchaînée le pays depuis ce cadeau
en miettes économiquement socialement
désastre sur le dr murray aurait perdu
la vie cet événement après son été des
pointes à limoges irait plus loin et les
chocs internationale aurait fait à la
réputation du canada et de la province à
il dresse quand tu prenable ben oui je
parlais du côté du chef ferrer vous
parle des chefs car au moment où ont eu
lieu ces événements ou cas vous étiez
des jo vous aviez commencé votre
carrière politique au sein du theil
attikameks montagne et et dieu sait que
le conseil attikameks montanier a
négocié avec le gouvernement du québec
avec le gouvernement du canada ça fait
40 ans que ça dure et pas d'entendre
encore à part à parler des nations
conventionnés
mon distasio les nations consignés y
attaquent d'antan territoriale encore et
même les innu qui sont là-haut sur le
bord de la rivière la musique à chypre
depuis des milliers d'années et aucune
reconnaissance alors où ça bloque pour
vous ce que je désire s je comprends
puisque le grand chef simon disait parce
que j'étais en quête ce top 20 des liens
de ce destin lié 130 entre les mâts
nation que je représentais et la
situation tend à canesta khéchana warg
et je voudrais qu'à ce moment là on
s'approchait lors de situations qui
auraient pu facilement dégénérer en une
situation qui serait devenu
incontrôlable même j'avais une approche
pour essayer de voir comment on peut
déstabiliser économiquement de québec à
travers à travers des situations donc
volonté l'eau à plogoff politique lors
du procès ont enquêté d'élitisme mais
une question de responsabilité
évidemment qu'il doit primer mais ceci
étant dit ce que ce que j'avais dans ce
rêve c'est que il faut retour arrière
aussi ses ports ses ports la première
manita sion deux juridictions
provinciales qui veut avoir mais ni sur
la question du territoire et de ses
ressources
il faut pas oublier que il ya eu
l'intervention musclée de la sûreté du
québec à rester gauche 1 200 cas la
question chômage frappant un harass a
été une autre intervention n'est
peut-être pas aussi musclé mais ça a été
une invention quand même avec matraques
et tout un gain pour la question du
saumon au ski et à travers sound grecque
est proche
récemment à washington et je pense que
ce que ça vient mettre en évidence
c'était que c'est vraiment le cas de
trois bancs d'essai le territoire et
je peux être pessimiste à outrance mais
la dernière en tant de vue au québec
c'est évidemment david james avec trois
autres nations
on va contribuer à donner à ses
nationaux rapport qui n'existe pas pour
les autres nations il n'y a pas autant
de pression au niveau social qui
permettrait aux orientations de pouvoir
peut-être avoir le même rapport de force
et avec le résultat on négocie à la
pièce on négocie des petits petit à
petit et en même temps ben on diminue le
rapport de peau ce qui existait pour
l'inaction conventionné à l'époque des
développements du développement de la
baie james et il faut pas non plus se
ride la population l'opinion générale
est d'avis que le québec se pètent les
bretelles encore aujourd'hui par
convention à 10 ans que honor vraiment
le modèle low grav une relation durable
avec une nation autochtone la convention
de betting de ses ports ses paniers de
la générosité de robert bresson celle de
l'obligation du gouvernement du québec
de l'époque de s'asseoir à denis
l'hostie
c'est cette obligation qui n'existe pas
actuellement gouvernement par prudence
il sans compter les ressources un qui
était disponible sur ce territoire qui
est essentiel le québec va diriger du
côté du ministre mais le jeu disait
encore votre lettre de mandat ou le prix
liste du dos rappelé que pour lui le
plus important ce sont les relations
avec les premières nations avec les
métis est avec nous et nous et
finalement les autochtones
alors face à une telle volonté face à
des niveaux d'investissement aussi qui
sont supérieures qui était auparavant
et évidemment avec l'administration
conservatrice ou sable au ministre pose
des questions essentiellement c'est que
si on a progressé
comme société dans nos relations ma
réponse est oui
trop long trop long trop lentement et de
façon de fait et de façon
inégal c'est le constat qu'on peut se
faire à travers l'historique est tracée
par le chef picard et à travers les
événements qu'on a tous vécu ce qui a
trait aux risques sismiques 3d 20
semaines et la marque avant ça les
limitations solidarité envers le peuple
souhaite
il reste beaucoup de fondement dans la
terre dont la réconciliation en ce qui a
trait aux griefs historique des droits
autochtones non reconnus primés coup sur
coup qu'il faut le reconnaître pour
pouvoir aller de l'avant
ça prend une reconnaissance après le
dialogue ça prend des développements et
l'effort combiné qui s'apprend un
travail acharné des berry les
investissements l'appui on se réjouit
comme gouvernement d'avoir investi des
milliards pour appuyer les peuples
autochtones les conditions puis la façon
de faire ça très importante et critiques
qu'on entend souvent ainsi que ça se
fait doux aux 2,306 libération avec la
mainmise sur les français dans ce qu il
faut qu ils se fassent au de faire le
problème c'est que comme politicien on
réfléchit trop souvent la transformation
ce n'est peut-être trop souvent se fait
de façon trop lente et de façon
générationnel alors vous m'avez parlé
la question qui m'est posée directement
c'est au niveau de la relation et ont
vécu cette relation façon intime dans
mon cabinet du premier ministre et au
sein des services aux autochtones je
peux vous dire que le constat que je
fais c'est que ça avance mais très
lentement et vu les événements des
derniers mois vous irez prévu si la
réfection con je pense qu'on doit se
poser non seulement que le gouvernement
fédéral m à travers les entités
provinciales territoriales et comme
canadien oui bon pendant d'une grande
contradictions qui traversent le
gouvernement
fédéral d'une part vous devrez
reconnaître pris la constitution aussi
vrai reconnaît les victoires autochtone
mais d'autre part le gouvernement
fédéral pour dépenser des centaines de
millions pour contester justement les
droits des autochtones d'encours
établissent un rapport de force qui
n'est pas nécessairement à favre kahn
alors comment vous expliquer cette non
la contradiction se situe plus souvent
que non dans le recours aux instances
judiciaires pour régler nos greffe rire
trigano nos problèmes nous avons fait un
effort de temps mais ce processus
un référent qui est incomplète répond
qu'il ne sera que complètent quant à
l'exécution de l'adoption de deux dalles
vu la procuration sur le droit du groupe
autochtone il son impact sur les tueries
dans le système judiciaire la ford du
bureau fédéral à droite du cerveau en or
à l'époque ce matin reste mais reste
plus devant canon qu'on se retrouve
qu'on se retrouve en cours oui chef
picard je vais retourner à vous comment
vont vos relations avec les différentes
instances gouvernementales
est-ce que ce cette crise d'oka qui a 30
ans est ce qu'on vit encore avec ses
conséquences d'un l'évasion avec les
entités gouvernement me crée une
impression en fait la meilleure façon
rapidement des réponses quand toujours
constamment un ace au québec et ottawa
on doit vraiment luz et de vigilance par
rapport à tout ce qui peut se dessiner
je dis aux cd de gouvernement avec
lesquels
tu auras ton de le traiter
je pense que jackson qui peut enlever ou
nier le fait qu'il ya eu des progrès
gouvernement fédéral sous un justin
trudeau tu redeviens 2015 sur plusieurs
formes comme en janvier vu une question
du territoire et ses doigts peut-être
qu'on a encore beaucoup beaucoup de
terrain à couvrir
et ça c'est sans compter des difficultés
nous avons avec gouvernement duquel
l'actuel gouvernement du québec qui à la
base de reconnaître l'existence d'une
gouvernance reporter qui serait propre à
nos nations donc c'est allé très très
loin et à utiliser qu ici que de partons
de très loin ici même d'arriver à une
étape où y aurait un agrément fin
transparent et clair avec le
gouvernement du québec
donc pour répondre à votre question on
ne tournait toujours je veux c'est la
constance chez lui on se revoyait en
sauvé ce qui se passe et on réagit en
fonction de ce qui peut nous surprend
dès fois dans les agissements des deux
gouvernements
mais ceci étant dit la question
territoriale demeure pour nous le nerf
de la guerre s'il n'y a pas d'avancée
significative sur ce terrain euros mais
n'est toujours finalement à la merci
d'un processus politique donc nous
arrivons difficilement à contrôler et de
la possibilité que les intérêts elle
laissait finalement devient des flammes
un peu comme on l'a vu avec la nation
watson sur la côte ouest des à l'époque
jeudi wall street est des situations
comme ça il adore tous pays tant que la
question territoriale demeure est temps
que mon apport un horizon prévisible
pour
règlement oui par l'ozone du territoire
parce que chez vous à cannes et sa
tactique c'est loin d'être réglé un
conflit territorial entre la communauté
d'autre part ne me dise pas lutter de la
municipalité on a de fait dès la
province
on aime à l'intérieur aussi des intérêts
qui vont les choses de la même façon une
réconciliation est temps qu'il faudra
voir le jour si on est pour voir du
progrès mais oui vous avez bien raison
que souvent on a des problèmes avec un
sein du gouvernement ça dépend de l'âge
comme de développement incident au kop
pas souvent c'est entre la municipalité
et la communauté
quand on voit lui les ressources de long
de l'audience pour la justice ou
éducation souhaite sur sa tombe avec
ottawa et on eu plusieurs choses dans
que dans nous comme la juridiction de
québec vu contre la province commentait
son approche les discussions avec la
province
st avoir un préjudice sur les lois du
jeu établies par litre et émouvant seuil
chanvrier malaise qu'on voit dans les
territoires liés à toutes sortes de
choses mais une principale c'est la dea
patriat sion taille qui nous ont été
promis d'arrêter et les ressources qui
vont avec oui je m'adresse aux ministres
mais le quai ce qu'il faudrait faire
tout le monde semble le grand chef simon
que le thé le territoire est au centre
même des revendications des nations
autochtones
ils tenteront pas au de ce désir
d'autonomie gouvernementale on sait très
bien que sans territoire
c'est une coquille qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire à court terme ou qu'ils avaient
quand même les moyens pour le faire
disponible dans lequel c'est un cépage
historiques qui remontent trois siècles
jusqu'à 10 718 dans le cadre du
règlement dentelle qui remonte une
douzaine d'années je perds de vue en
2008 qui est que l'on que l'on discute
avec le conseil qui aura kiki qui défend
franchement leurs intérêts leurs
revendications historiques
ainsi quelques jeux ce n'est pas quelque
chose que l'on négocié sur d'abord et
avant tout sur la place publique par
respect d'abord et avant tout à la
communauté de gana guèye merci quelque
chose je vous ai dit 2008 qui de trailer
progresse très lentement mais ce n'est
pas un manque de mauvaises le contraire
il ya beaucoup de discussions épineuses
qui doivent se régler sinon tenait qu'à
moi j'aimerais aussi lancé cette
discussion et c'est la même chose il ya
beaucoup de passion surtout à ce temps
ci de l'année dans la région de déléguer
au cas mais ce sont quelque ce sont des
choses qui ne peut se régler sans des
discussions franches en est ouverte avec
ses quelque chose que l'on doit être
farouche la façon dont dédié outre le
problème de façon de façon délibérée
délibéré il est en bonne foi jamais à
prendre huit ans apprend la patience et
sa princesse se demande d'aidé
évidemment ce dévouement
oui de voter ce feu car qu'est ce qui
pouvait être fait court terme pour
débloquer une situation qui semble
encore un peu stagnant de reconnaissance
des droits territoriaux ct je dirais
profitons du moment
les trois ici jeu notamment pertes
ministre d'erreur déterministe qui est
quand même bien vu bien biais dont
l'opinion au sein des communautés à
travers le pays
et quand même très polis qui sortira
pour un ministre qui spéculent la
relation entre le gouvernement fédéral
et l'ensemble de la communauté donc
profitons de settat kg et essayons
d'avancer de des progrès sur cet élément
dont qui s'avère vital je pense que
personne aucun leader à travers le pays
qui veut dire dans un processus de dix
ans à trouver des solutions durables sur
la question tolérable et et si j'avance
trop c'est que on vous l'a dit vous
l'avez évoqué un peu plus tôt on a un
premier ministre qui juge par le fait
qu'il n'y a pas de relation plus
importante avec les peuples autochtones
on parle beaucoup et on fait valoir la
question de la relation nationaux mais
en même temps on sait aussi qu'il y a
des relents d'égouts qui ont été
marquées dans le passé dont le
rendez-vous constitutionnel qui a fait
en stop finalement ces deux buts et un
mur au milieu des années 80 et je me
souviens d'ailleurs je ne citerai pas
mais je me souviens du commentaire d'un
commentaire de rené lévesque à l'époque
et premier ministre sous québec qui
disait finalement la question jeudi à le
donner
le cru du problème de leucate avancer
cette question de pouvoir et de
territoire il avait entièrement raison
et c'est là aujourd'hui que pour moi les
et peut-être d'une concession un parfait
c'est le vaincu les lions une main mise
de la part des provinces soit pas
question territoire et des ressources
et c'est là que j'ai
joue en quelque sorte appelons ça une
contradiction d'un côté l'autre on parle
de cette nation c'est notre relation
sacrée de nation à nation de
l'importance des enjeux octobre puis
entendait on ferme la porte à tout tout
tout tout forum qui permettrait une
amende de s'adapter de presse un peu
plus durable est beaucoup plus
égalitaire aussi par rapport à la nation
oui mais quand on parle de la
constitution dieu sait que c'est un
challenge de trédrez l'ex je terminerais
si vous voulez le temps est en fait il
sait pas pour apparaître comme en
spectaculaire où chercher le comment
dire la première page sensationnaliste
mais que de tels événements comme la
crise d'oka il ya trente ans mais se
répéter aujourd'hui chef sinon à quoi
bon quand on voit que l'état demande
aujourd'hui c'est instable
la seule chose qui empêche la une au
christ et la bonne foi en les hommes et
lui les fang voir nos mains et nous est
d'essayer d'apprendre des agents les
erreurs du port de peaux les répéter je
le vois comme avec un ministre heureux
moi j'ai toujours apprécié le dui sait
que c'est son accessibilité
moi je me suis un bon quand j'avais un
mini ce que je pouvais appeler se monte
la formulation un messager de la paix
sont vendus à des augmentations en
donnant pour l'éducation apprécié de vue
d'aider progresser autonation malsain
mais on fait des bonnes à jeter des
ponts entre les marches ensemble on ne
lit pas d'intervention sur les deux os
des data met en cause qui nous bloque
comme j'aime à ce que les tantôt c'est
souvent les hauts niveaux de
gouvernement qui se met en place
en province c'est des choses culturelles
sur le monde et sur ce point d'être
ensemble approuvé le dialogue parce
qu'il ya la crise au col la cupide
raison c'est de l'ignorance
le manque de lait et les ici en quatre
ans
comprendre le lot l'événement musical
complet qui on est ils traiter les eaux
internationales la constitution et on
rentre dans cent ans cette recette ne
peut-être qu'on a évité une crise nous
avons craint de voir que les taux des
côtés de brad chef car est ce que vous
pensez vous que de tels événements comme
la crise d'oka est ce que vous pensez
que ça ça pourrait se reproduire encore
ajouté
on vit tous la pandémie actuellement on
sait aussi que cette crise actuelle
était précédée par une crise qu avec la
nation est souhaitée et on a vu le même
mouvement de solidarité exprimée à
travers le pays
il dément pas avec autant d'intensité
que ce qu'on a vu 990 milliards demeure
pas moins que la paix la paix sociale
était menacée clairement ici et quand on
nous chante lui qu'en 1990 on n'avait
pas les eaux se prendra aujourd'hui
parce que ça aurait pu passer dégénérer
comme on le dit un peu plus tôt et c'est
possible que ça dégénère encore
aujourd'hui uniquement par biais des
attaques à travers ce trans qui existe
comme réseaux sociaux parmi nous c'est
là une réalité aussi et je pense qu'on
doit tenir compte
mais une chose qui doit être la main
mise au clair c'est le fait que le
stream à une population et
particulièrement chez les jeunes
il y aura également c'est le mobiliser
lyon qui est toujours latente qui est là
qui est au rendez vous et je pense que
les jeunes sont extrêmement motivés les
leaders de dépendre des conférences
conditionnelle avait déjà prédit
d'ailleurs on est peut-être plus
complaisant que le seront les jeunes
générations touchées
donc c'est en train d'arriver
actuellement et pour moi ça pourrait
effectivement russe a peut être d'autres
crises mais ce sur une autre fois mais
l'objectif de marge de man oui monsieur
le ministre mais rebours on sait que
vous êtes un homme de paix quel est
votre objectif pour éviter justement que
ce type d'événement sur rose du jaune
aux deux chefs la question si ça
pourrait se reproduire puis je suis
d'accord et accule ça pour elle et on
est si je prends par exemple les
événements du mouvement solaire pour les
oiseaux et les barricades sont les voies
ferroviaires
mais les gens créent ou ça il y avait
les réseaux sociaux très dangereux une
plus grande menace c'est cette phase
unis de négocier de négocier par un
réseau social interposés à se regarder
dans les yeux se dire les vraies
affaires
j'ai vécu à l'inter du cabinet cette
volonté de ne pas envoyer l'armée en
verre pour se battre le premier ministre
l'a dit très clairement mais encore
fallait-il négocié par l'ue ouvertes
avec les gens qui étaient lost aura des
voies ferroviaires ou pour dans le cas
de madame bennett en colombie
britannique est sur dur et huawei sur
une face à face prendre le temps d'y
aller aller dialoguer le combat comme
des deux chefs l'ont suivi ni ses
comptes ignorance qui persistent les
canadiens et québécois les peuples
autochtones veulent tous la paix mr
comme si le déployer les grands moyens
pour y arriver pour s'assurer que cela
ne se reproduise plus il ça passe par la
patience les par le dialogue et les
auteurs
viendront à l'appui mais je ne peux pas
vous dire avec certitude que j'ai une
crainte avec les enjeux
socio-économiques chapitre notamment
signé oui évidemment il ya une jeunesse
dynamique autochtone bien et bien
éduqués qui ne veut revoir ni ce qu'est
ce que la génération précédente a vécu
il refusera il faut respecter ce choix
mais ça prend encore un dialogue plus
intime avec dirigeants et peuple et ça
ça s'apprend est favori et que la force
intellectuelle que la vo fais du cadam
oui ce d'autant plus que les nations
autochtones se caractérise par le fait
qu'elles sont des gens qui sont jaunes
se sont dits nation qui connaissent
impeccable bd ou alors il faut en tenir
compte bien sûr alors il me reste à vous
remercier à grand chef ciment le cas
grec et de canet et s'attaque immersive
où pouvoir pour ce témoignage chef
ghislain picard merci beaucoup aussi de
votre témoignage de votre collaboration
régulière à l'espace entre autochtones
et monsieur le ministre en erreur merci
beaucoup d'autres générosité je sais que
vous avez eu une très grosse journée au
parlement aujourd'hui
donc merci beaucoup à vous trois et on
souhaite à nous tous bien sûr merci
beaucoup à la maison qui aviez été là
tout au long de cette émission
au revoir une prochaine
[Musique]